i
would love to introduce michael lepic he
is an associate professor of civil and
environmental engineering and a senior
fellow at the woods institute for the
environment at stanford university
as an instructor he has taught numerous
executive education and professional
education courses
on topics of finance leadership
sustainability and
entrepreneurship in the us brazil france
korea south africa and china he has
co-founded
four companies in the u.s and china
based on his research and advanced
construction materials
michael joined the stan join stanford
university faculty from
university of michigan school of natural
resources and environment
michael fores is an executive leader in
boeing's leadership
learning and organizational capability
lloc
team driving transformation toward a
2025 vision
before boeing he was an executive leader
of learning at microsoft
transforming microsoft sales consulting
services
and other divisions to achieve
microsoft's digital transformation
vision
michael is an adjunct professor at
stanford university and the university
of washington
where he teaches numerous courses on
innovation and entrepreneurism
with that i'm going to go ahead and turn
it over to our wonderful speakers today
so you can all enjoy
the wealth of knowledge they have to
share with you thank you michael and
michael
thanks thanks hannah and and uh dr
forrest thank you so much
for taking the time uh to spend with me
today
to chat about you know this this um this
really cool topic
of of entrepreneurship so you know
i'd like to to frame today's discussion
uh around um sort of uh for those that
are familiar with
late night u.s television um sort of a a
david letterman style top ten
uh in which in which we talk about some
of the the top ten
things that can happen anywhere and in
this case
if if it's possible i'd like to to talk
about the
the top 10 things that that can go wrong
with the startup you know talk about
some failure modes and i think by
by looking at those things that can that
can go wrong
i think there's a tremendous amount to
to learn there
in in how to prevent the things from
going wrong and how to make them
go right and i know there's a few of
these
that i think you think are you're
thinking are probably more important
than others and maybe we can spend a
little bit of a little more time on them
does that sound okay
sounds perfect to me thanks for inviting
me i'm glad to be here with you
all right so uh number 10
once again not in any order of
importance but um
but one that i actually think is
incredibly important uh number 10 is
going to be
um competitive landscape um
how is this a challenge and and and how
should startups think about this
yeah and i'll just say thanks you know
thanks again for having me it's april
fool's day right so i was a little leery
when you said hey let's do this on april
1st i was like okay what's going on
what's mr lupin might have some
shenanigans up his sleeve
but yeah so landscape i think is really
important and by the way everything
we're going to talk
about is a system of interdependencies
uh for a startup so
there are lots of numerous failure
points as we go through these top ten
they're all
interlinked as i think about them and
you know i'll just say as we start too
that you know 70 to 80 percent of
startups fail
we're going to going to talk about the
top 10 list of reasons why they fail and
what you can do about them
in terms of landscape i'll just say in
my mind the world is spinning
a bit faster and it's so funny because i
was researching
uh i was doing a class for columbia you
actually
recently and i was looking at my whole
this part of my hypothesis about future
work and how it's changing was
that it feels like the world's spinning
faster partly because of the fourth
industrial revolution and all this
accelerating technology
and then i went to look at the world
economic forum and there's some
scientific proof that the world will
spin a little bit one second faster this
year
than other years crazy i know but in
terms of landscape
i think that means things are changing
more quickly particularly because we had
the pandemic
you have you know coco unemployed then
you have the fourth industrial
revolution technology still
progressing all the stuff in the cloud
and so if you're a startup you've got to
be watching your landscape
more closely than ever because it's
shifting faster than ever
and you know the the best thing that i
think we've seen over the years as we've
taught to startups is is the the idea of
a pestle p-e-s-t-l-e you may have heard
of that but it's really looking at the
the political economic social technical
legal and environmental factors that
could impact your startup
and i'll just say real quickly because
it's changing more rapidly you shouldn't
just do that once
which is a lot of what startups do they
do it once for a
v1 product you need to do it every three
to six months
or even more often because the the
competition's changing and the landscape
shifting
much more quickly these days now i think
that i think that pestle framework is is
really useful in this case the other
thing i would say
about competitive landscape is making
sure that you really
understand who your actual competitors
are
right and and not only looking at
companies that appear to be doing the
same thing
but companies that are also offering a
similar value proposition to the
customer
right you know um uh zoom is not only
competing with
with skype and with teams and with
others but also with many other
different types
of co-working platforms and even regular
offices
uh when when when people are allowed to
return road return
offices and so seeing that competitive
landscape as broadly as possible from
the customer viewpoint
i think is is it's the you know that the
pistol framework is is really helpful in
allowing folks to do that
yeah maybe one quick follow-up there too
that i see is
people sometimes they'll say oh there's
we don't have any competition we're
in a really new space maybe a new
technology well that's probably not true
because
um players that are normally not in one
industry are moving into different
industries and we've seen that at boeing
with spacex right spacex came in
um and really is taking a share of the
satellite market
um so so you have to watch out for other
players who are who are is part of this
disruption that's happening
uh fueled by these new technologies in
the cloud
but people will move into other
industries and markets and by the way
big companies are always watching
startups
to either you know hopefully buy them
out if you're a startup you'd like that
but also maybe just run over the top of
them once they see that there's an
opportunity
that a that a startup is starting to you
know take advantage of
yeah first mover advantage or first
mover advantage is a bit of a fallacy
um in many regards right so number nine
market uh how can market be a a source
of failure um in uh
if for a new startup yeah we have some
colleagues at stanford who
who you know really really pushed for
this one as a top priority because
there's so much failure around it and
it's a lot of it's around the size of
the opportunity
um so it does link to scaling but but
also
it's segmentation like who are you going
after first we see startup folks really
conflicted about who who their their
target market is
and how they're going to segment it who
do they go after first second third
fourth what order what speed um and that
creates just
a whole lot of chaos um in a startup
because they're really unclear
about the audience that they're going to
serve first and how to meet their needs
and then have it flow
into future audiences so how much you
customize and tailor for a first segment
versus having you know the the messaging
and the product and its features be
able to flow into other markets
afterwards um so i think segmentation is
key
and then how to sell which channels and
and also pricing is
is an issue being able to really set a
price that that's that's valid and
and you can rely upon you know
talking about some some red flags just
like you said a red flag
is we don't have any competitors that's
never true everyone has competitors
similarly when we ask folks who's your
market everyone's my market
that's also a big red flag no not
everyone
is your market and and if you think
that's the case then you then you don't
have enough focus to truly be able to
serve anyone really well
um and and and so uh even the most
successful products i mean if we think
about something like windows right
where where a license on windows still
gets sold every second of the day or
every couple seconds of the day
um one of the most successful products
you know ever
um even even that doesn't serve everyone
and um and and so i think it's a great
point um
all right number eight financials
and this isn't just about raising money
raising money is always a challenge
but this is more than just raising money
yeah this is
really where a lot of hard work has to
be done a lot of details need to be
figured out
and the the decisions and assumptions
that get made in a financial model and a
financial plan
are really strategic decisions that
drive your startup
and you've got to be able to answer the
tough questions about
really the product its features the
competition the timing
all of it plays into a financial model
so those assumptions and decisions
really set
a lot of your strategy if you haven't
already figured it out
but you should know your income your
expenses your assets your cash flow
and then how much external money you
want because we
you know vc money is the most expensive
money you'll ever uh
receive uh you know they're expecting
like a 90x return
at least and so you've got to be careful
because then that
also dilutes your ownership so a lot
plays into this in cap tables and
and ownership um but but you've got to
have your arms around the financials and
there are people who are
really strong product people who don't
really want to deal with financials much
a bit so you got to get help where you
can um because financials
is some it's something that you need to
know as a startup leader
and and you've got to do the due
diligence on it
yeah it's um it's it's it's an
interesting point in
in that you know when you talk to an
investor
they're going to and you say look i'm
i'm looking to raise
i'm looking to raise you know five
million dollars on a 20
share um their first question will be
why 5 million what do you need it for
and if that number just comes out of
thin air
um that's that's another one of those
red flags
right i want to know exactly what does
your operating stack look like
you know what are you going to spend
this money on this quarter next quarter
and the quarter after
uh you know and without having those
specifics for folks to drill down
you know so much about venture capital
and investing like this is about trust
because you truly have to trust the
people you're going into business with
which your investor is going into
business with you and if you don't have
those numbers to back it up
um and to understand those financials
that trust will never be built
yeah totally agree totally agree
um all right next up and this is one of
our heavy hitters um out of the out of
the top 10 number six
product how does product get messed up
yeah well the product is where
a lot of people focus and for good
reason it needs to be
really clear what the product is and
some startup leaders have trouble
describing their product
and maybe it's because they haven't also
prioritized features
and know exactly what the customer wants
and will pay for
in in a v1 or a next next version
and so being really clear and
prioritizing what the product is what
its features are
and doing research around the product to
make sure it's differentiated with
competitors
um you know if you're looking to
research it and
you know look into standard sources like
gartner that's too late you know that's
those are lagging
research data if you're really cutting
edge and differentiated there's probably
not much written about your
your product and its competitors so the
thing you need to do is talk to
customers you need to go out and develop
some personas and really think through
you know what what are the features that
this product needs and again it plays
into market segmentation you know how
does it play into that first segment
and future segments of what you're
building and every
it's about scope you know of prioritized
features and and
startups just aren't really clear on
that every every feature you decide to
do
is a trade-off for a feature you're not
doing and so being clear about that i
think is really critical
yeah i i i it's it's true that you you
you only have so much time
can you talk a little bit about
particularly for folks coming from uh
maybe from larger companies how product
development and product
uh uh coming up with that product is a
little bit different
at a big company versus at a startup and
sort of what some of those
differences might be for folks coming
from
uh industry having worked for a big
company wanting to think about a startup
and yes a lot of it starts with that
product idea
how is that product development process
a little bit different
yeah coming to the use of page from
microsoft i led a strategy team there
and we looked at
uh intrapreneurism and how that plays
out
you know some things are similar in the
sense that prioritizing features is
critical
uh you know it's at a big company they
may have enough resources where they can
pivot and throw more money and resources
that's something to recover if if
they're seeing that something's not
working a startup you may not have you
may have a more
you know thin edge of resources to be
able to pivot as often and throw as many
resources at it
you don't want to burn through a whole
lot of vc money um
you know in in a haphazard way so but
but some things that are similar
getting priority around the features i
mean i when i was at microsoft
it you know it's a lot of product folks
are technologists and they they
feel they can do anything and and so
it's not okay just because you can build
it
that you need to go build it you know
it's it's like
you get bloated feature sets that you
can't um
accomplish in a timeline to meet a
market window because all this is meant
to to achieve a market window
where your product's gonna be hot in the
market and so
um i've seen it happen where you get you
know too many features
product managers fighting over which
features should go in
you know all saying that they have
customer data um and
and it gets it gets too bloated and you
can't meet the timeline so suddenly you
need to start cutting out features
um in a startup backing that could that
can ruin you so you got to be really
careful
up front and go conservatively with a
with a first version knowing you can add
things and face things in over time
now it's it's it's um it's it
it's a bit of a balancing act between
sort of making sure you don't have that
bloated
product with a ton of features and yet
delivering
um you know thinking back to to to jeff
moore's concept of
of a whole product solution right
you want to make sure that you don't
bloat it with features that aren't
necessarily
offering value proposition to your
focus nero customer segment but also
this notion of whole product solution
where you're providing the entire
solution not just
one little bitty widget in a much bigger
thing
which big companies understand well and
so can you talk a little also maybe a
little bit about this juxtaposition
between whole product solution
and that bloated features um yeah for
sure i mean it's what's the you know
minimum viable product that meets the
customer need
and yet what we also see and this
happened in a lot of the stanford
programs is the startup folks think
about the technology or the product
itself and its features
and struggle with that but don't think
about the whole product model you know
what other kinds of services can be
provided along with that that generate
value that can
you can charge for what about training
what about ongoing
you know work there's a story out of
france that that i
that i love um you know there was new
technology to have sensors to monitor
nuclear power plants and dams and
and you know the the gentleman created
it out of his garage basically
and had this really cool technology that
he had developed to to sense
if something was wrong with a a plant or
a factory
and and he went to the the leader of of
you know who managed these dams and you
know dams if they break you have all
these villages downstream in cities that
people will people die and so
you know he he said hey you know i've
got this cool technology and
and the leader said well you know um you
know let's see it so they did a demo and
he's like well what are you charging for
it and he just said well you know for
the software i don't know maybe i don't
know what you know twelve
thousand euros and then the leader of
the damn started laughing
and he's like are you kidding me do you
know what happens if a damn breaks
and and why haven't you thought through
the services and and and the maintenance
and the training of my people he goes do
you know what my budget is to try to
keep these dams safe and these
and similarly for nuclear power plants
and and
and you know our friendly startup um
gentleman who went through our program
by the way and so we helped him
said well i think i could go back and
think through some of these these whole
product
uh features but if i did that you know
what what would you be willing to pay
and the leader of the dam said how about
um 300
000 euros per for for the dam
and and our startup ceo said whoa
okay great you know he tried to keep his
composure and then and then the leader
said
by the way i have 12 dams and i'll pay
000 for each damn so so it's that kind
of story about whole product model
totally totally totally um all right
next up
number five technology disruption
uh how can that be a a a challenge when
it comes to
startups yeah oh my gosh i talk about
this a lot because this is really
fourth industrial revolution and just
quickly if you're not familiar with it
i'll just
say real real fast the first one you
know was all
eighteen hundreds you know think charles
dickens mechanization
uh you know it was all about steam and
water power
um so think you know factories in
london's belching out smoke
and then fast forward nineteen hundreds
henry ford assembly line
electricity that was the next one the
second revolution third was
the the personal computing revolution
people still think we're there
uh you know it servers in the basement
but we've moved in and the holy grail at
microsoft was to put the operating
system in the cloud and so having azure
or
aws from amazon and having cloud
technology has changed the world
and we don't even realize all the
computing power now that we have
it's not just putting excel and and
powerpoint word
in the cloud is ai it is machine
learning it is
advanced robotics it's quantum computing
that's coming
this disruption is changing the world
and will change all of our lives it'll
affect
healthcare manufacturing agriculture
everything
and so this is a great opportunity for
all of you as startup folks because
it is a it is a you know greenfield
blank canvas and people are moving in
fast
uh because there's a lot of disruption
of markets happening but it also
means if you're a startup person you've
got to watch this because things are
changing out from under you
it's not okay to do an analysis of your
competition in the technology
and then just assume as you build out v1
over the course of months and
a year that nothing has changed and
that's where startups will fail is
they're not staying up
on the the technology that's changing
every few months
i mean doing a startup is not a
full-time job
it's like four full-time jobs and so
it's it's hard to kind of
keep abreast of everything that's going
on while also keeping your head down and
focused on what you need to do that day
which is which is where really great
investors can be important
because and forming that that advisory
board and that board of directors when
you get to the point where you're taking
institutional money
because ideally they can also help you
to stay abreast of all of those all
those things yeah
indeed all right um uh
let's see here where are we now i think
we're on number seven um
and um uh and and this is a this is a
biggie oh excuse me number six
uh a biggie um customer need how does
customer need play into
a potential failure mode yeah i mean
this
so much hinges on this probably
everything you know we talked about the
prioritized feature set but it's
it's how well people can articulate you
know basically a problem statement in
one sentence or
in the customer need or pain in one
sentence and
and is it really clear you know if
you're starting to look at
who your market is how you segment it um
it connects to everything else right
financials prioritize features
but being really clear that you're
solving this customer need or pain
and you're looking to do it uniquely or
differentiated from everyone else
it's not okay to just come along as a
startup and and you know reinvent what
some big companies already doing to meet
needs you just won't succeed because
then you have problems with loyalty and
trying to
acquire customers which we'll we'll also
talk about um but
but it's it's really honing in on that
customer need that you can uniquely meet
that is differentiated you know we
always said at microsoft the customer is
king or queen
you know the customer is it's all about
the customer
and you know it worst case you you stay
disconnected from the customer and
you're not close enough and haven't done
enough sampling to really understand the
customer don't have
any early testimonials and you know
first first adopters
we see startup people who feel like
they're assuming they know what's needed
and can be very wrong and haven't and
then we say
who have you talked to which customers
how many and they can't tell us or it's
only been not two or three
you know that's not enough and and you
know some product people
they're very much into the technology
maybe a little more introverted and
don't want to get out and talk to
customers it's uncomfortable
but but it's got to be done by someone
and who's really out there
um informing the startup because
everything flows from that customer need
and pain it's
it it formulates the strategy or vision
of the startup
which which then everything flows from
that strategy and vision
yeah you know in the in the um in the
venture capital investing uh programs
that we that we do i use a line from uh
from a famous silicon valley
investor that when you when you meet
with an entrepreneur
um what you're really what you want to
hear from them and so for those that are
thinking about you know doing the
kind of elevator pitch too quick quick
thing um
we tell them make attraction sandwich
talk about traction do your customers
really
need your product and what kind of
traction are you having with real
customers who are paying these are not
freemium things these are not users that
are just doing it for free or
or or or you know friends and family
that are trying it out who are real
customers that are liking product so
first thing talk about traction
second thing talk about whatever it is
you're doing and then the third thing
talk again about traction and so you
want to make that traction sandwich
traction pitch traction because
for an investor traction's everything
if you can show that customers truly
need your product
and are willing to pay for it everything
else
will flow and so yeah we we tell we tell
folks
in pitching for quick pitches traction
sandwich
and then that goes right back to
customer need
that's great love it yeah next up one as
a university faculty member that's near
and dear to my heart
research and development and how
investors
don't fund research projects
yeah there's some great case studies
where uh
people were funded with you know multi
millions of dollars from vcs and the
product
still needed a lot more research and
development and so you burn through all
your money
trying to finish uh research and
development to even get to
productization
and you know that happens in bing cos
too you know where where
you're you have a research and
development team that's building out
something or thinking they're going to
help you know infuse something in a
product and it's not ready and it's hard
to transfer over and all that
but for a startup knowing how much more
r d
is needed for a product and if it can
really even be done
you know because there's sometimes great
ideas that get funded
and and there's a big assumption that
yes um
you know we leap of faith that we can
finish this research and development and
then you find out oh it can't
it can't even be done we're certainly
not in the timeline with the money we
have
so being really astute about you know
really
how much r d is left and and can we do
it can it really be done
and then of course there's the the
problem of that's great that you did the
r d
can you create a prototype and can it be
you know potentially mass produced you
know whether it's digital or
physical um can you scale it as a
product
can it get productized there are some
great products sitting out there that
they can't
scale enough to be productized we've
talked about advanced
battery technology how to live or more
labs it exists
it just is too expensive to scale too
many expensive you know products need
their materials need to go into it and
it's just there's there's not the
manufacturing capability to make it
scale for a startup
so so that's one example but but that
gives it some of the r d and
productization piece
well and and i and one of the other
pieces to that is
is also this often a a misunderstanding
by the founder of the entrepreneur
on the the cost distribution between
research and development
um uh you know you feel great when when
when the research is done
you've got this the the idea works
and then you're like okay we're almost
there um
development is far more expensive and
this gets to that productization develop
development is actually more expensive
than the initial research
because you have to get to that point
where it is productizable
and so as you think about the financials
you know we were talking before about
how everything's connected together
making sure that you realize that
development
is going to be 3x or more expensive than
all the research you had to do to get to
this point
and making sure that you're budgeting
for that appropriately
with regard to fundraising and also with
the staff and other resources you're
gonna need to get there
yeah there's a there's a great story
about uh e-ink
you know the ink that's used for the
kindle um where
they received a lot of venture capital
money originally and and
and failed because they hadn't done
enough research and they couldn't get it
to a state of development where they
could productize it
and so the company went bankrupt the
startup it failed
uh but but a couple people kept the idea
going in their garage
and and found a way to not only finish
the research on
on their own but also then to get it to
that productization development stage
where
where people could actually buy it but
it took the startup failing first before
it could come back from the ashes
yeah right on all right another one of
our heavy hitters
coming down to the last few on the uh on
a top 10 list
um and this is this one i know is near
and dear to your heart with your
background
uh leadership team and culture how can
that be a problem for a a startup or a
small team
oh my gosh there's so much to talk about
here and this is you know this gets
called the number one reason why
startups fail everyone thinks it's
financials or it's the product or it's
the go-to-market
the the leadership team and culture can
make something fail more quickly and
and faster and worse than anything else
um
you know most people don't have a good
plan around this they just assume we'll
start bringing people on board and we'll
just you know find good people who have
um expertise that can help us and not
really anybody
my buddy my buddy knows how to do
something let's have him do it yeah
oh yeah a lot of times you know friends
and buddies and
yeah and so then when the or
we always tell phone if you've got too
many people with the same last name
on the cap table this is not an
investigative company
yeah it's a hobby it's a family business
keep it that way don't try to make it a
startup that's going to scale
globally you know just keep it a hobby a
family business in private if you want
but yeah so as you start to bring people
together i mean first of all there's a
leadership
issue the the leader who got the idea
started and maybe got it funded
with vc money may absolutely not be the
right person to lead the company forward
and and because they can't build an
organization a high performing
organization
that really can can execute and scale a
product
maybe they they're all about the big
ideas and
and you know we have some leaders today
who get who get in big companies that
were startups
who get criticized for being big idea
people who can't execute
um i won't call it any names but you can
guess a few probably from the media
uh and yeah and leopard knows who you
knew how i'm talking about mr living
so anyway the the leadership is a is a
real issue
you don't want to have to fire a ceo or
cto and i've been involved in that
actually in startups and it's brutal um
i was involved in a situation where
the cto was was you know a little bit of
a bully and
and the the chief software developer
really you know great kind of um you
know a
larger stature man really tall you know
we
we were meeting as a leadership team and
talking about the issues that startup
was having
having and uh when everyone walked out
of the room and i was
sitting with this this gentleman he he
actually started having tears
because he felt like he'd been bullied
by the cto so much so
actually it you know got involved in the
firing of this cto which was kind of
brutal
but worse is firing a ceo because that's
a chance really where the venture
capitalists if there's money involved
will
feel like they need to swoop in and
actually take over and so talk about
ownership
dilution you know if you or or a chance
for a startup to fail is when
when people see that a ceo has to be
taken out
and by the way it's worse though if a
ceo stays and they're not they're really
bad as a leader because people start not
wanting to come and work
um with with that in that startup
they'll start not showing up
and and you'll see all kinds of cultural
issues but a lot of things go into this
leadership team and culture it's the
culture and values
we've seen startups that have grown that
have struggled um
with their culture and you've seen um
uber having that problem for example you
know they had major culture issues
around culture and values
so not not doing this intentionally and
having a strategy
there's a whole leadership system that
that i teach that gets a leadership team
and culture
to really create a high performing
organization if you don't have that
which most people don't and they don't
think about it it's a real chance for
failure
yeah so when when we're teaching our
venture capital investing right and
we're giving people pointers on so what
do you look for in those early stages
we say the first thing you look for is
team the second thing you look for is
team
the third thing you look for is team and
then you can start looking at some other
things because
a great team will always figure it out
a second class team will screw up even
the best
ideas yeah so we think that
you know you invest in people not in
companies
yeah i think that's a great point yeah
the vcs are looking to see what kind of
background you have
uh what how you how strong you are as a
leader do you have a good team around
you is the team really
working well together they'll invest in
that first thinking that the
the financials and the product will
pivot maybe numerous times and they
they assume that they're okay with that
it doesn't have to stay the same product
and feature set and financials that that
they pitched to get the money
and so they're investing in that the
people in the team first
to to make those pivots and bring
something to life
you know it kind of goes back to that
comment i made about trust right and you
have to trust
people you cannot trust a product you
cannot trust a
a a um you know a specific go-to-market
strategy you have to trust
um people some of these
intangibles right i mean everyone wants
to focus on
you know ones and zeros and technology
and and financials and
and yet it comes down to the intangibles
a lot of times whether a startup makes
it or not
yeah that comes into some of the due
diligence stuff that we talk about
sometimes like due diligence
on what you know this is a nice this is
an idea
three people and a passion um what am i
gonna do
due diligence on other than maybe those
individuals
all right come on the last couple
customer acquisition um
i think this has a lot to do with how
hard it is to acquire customers
well yeah so this is an area that i see
startup folks not
focus on enough they assume if the
technology is good enough if it's
differentiated and has the right feature
set that you build it and they will come
but there's a cost to acquiring
customers that's often not thought about
until someone has to sit down and put
pencil to paper
around the financials it's like what i
have to figure out how much it cost to
acquire one customer and then multiply
that times how many customers i think
i'll have
it's just something that startup folks
don't think about enough
and it is there's it can be expensive to
acquire customers you have to think
through your marketing and sales
approach
and and so that needs to be built in and
then the other piece that goes right
along with that is retention and loyalty
um so if you do get them how do you keep
them and make them loyal
but one thing we see a lot of is you
know the thought that well
we're just going to acquire customers
even if the customers are
have some other product that they like
and they're using from some other
company like a big co
a big company and so you know try to
acquire customers who are loyal to apple
um you know that's not easy and you're
probably not going to do it
because people are super loyal to
another product and company even if it
doesn't have exactly the feature set
that you might be offering
because yours is differentiated you
can't just assume because you have a
certain product and technology that
you build it they're going to come and
you're just like a magnet going to
attract all these
people with money who are going to
switch over to you yeah
uh you know you talked about um you know
how hard it is to acquire customers
this notion of oh it's just going to go
viral nothing
very few things if anything goes viral
on its own there's a lot going on behind
the scenes to push
virality forward uh and and so to think
that your product well it's just gonna
catch on and go viral
that is not a go to market strategy that
is that the hope
that it will will will be very difficult
to rely upon
all right our last one and it's one that
any successful startup should
should will have to cope with um but can
certainly be a
a source of a failure scale
yeah a lot of startups think small and
one of the things we do at stanford
which i love
and and it's a silicon valley mentality
i think is
it's about going big um you know there
was a
at microsoft there was a phrase that was
the unwritten cultural rule which is go
big or go home
and and with startups i think you've got
to think bigger
um it's it and it's that makes it more
difficult
it's not just a small you know product
you're going to sell around a city or
even a region and we see this
as we worked in in europe a lot with the
eu
you know some of the folks in france
have thought just about the french
market and maybe just the northern
french market
and we're like no think all france think
all you think global
and and that that means you've got to
rethink your vision and strategy
and and your financials and your go to
market and so
everything flows from the size and scale
and speed that you want to go
to the scale but if you are truly
cutting edge
differentiated say you're working on
some new fourth industrial revolution
technology that's never been done in the
world
and you really have done your research
and homework you should want to go big
and so we encourage people to think big
but you've got to then
scale everything associated with the the
product
and its features and financials and go
to market strategy and everything else
to to go big you know phasing in a
strategy smart in a smart way you know
region by region country by country
because you have different laws in
different countries that would allow you
go into to go into their markets
and so that gets at the scaling
complexity is where can you go
where should you go in what order and we
see startup folks struggling with that
first even conceptualizing going big and
then really
starting to struggle to think through
which regions which countries in which
order
yeah no it's it's it's absolutely it's
absolutely uh it's absolutely true
all right so that's that's the top ten
well roughly the top ten lists
i think it was really good we're gonna
actually shift over some questions we
got some great questions
coming in from from the from the
participants um
so the the first one is is really
related to some of your experience
at big companies but also working with
startups and you already alluded a
little bit to the difference between
being an intrapreneur working at a big
company but trying to be but working to
be entrepreneur and an
entrepreneur when we talked a little bit
about product development stuff like
this
what are some other you know big
differences
between entrepreneurship and
entrepreneurship especially
vis-a-vis folks that might want to
transition
from being you know in in a big company
to starting their own company because
they think they've got a great idea
yeah you know i've seen it go both ways
actually i've been on the acquiring side
where i've had leaders
of startups that we acquired report to
me
and that was interesting because that's
a different culture set and mentality of
coming into a big co
but then also at big companies you know
use microsoft as an example everyone
wanted to go do a startup
and and so then the question is do they
want to give their ideas to microsoft
you know their best ideas can they go
work on them will microsoft support them
which microsoft is pretty good at you
know listening to ideas and seeing if it
was a new feature for a product or a new
whole new product um or does the
individual want to save something
uh special for themselves and go do a
startup and and i've seen people go do
startups and come back to big cos
you know you know we call them retreads
at microsoft they
they go off to a startup come back but
the idea that they could go off and do a
startup was often a dream for them
and because they felt like they
understood enough of the elements
having developed product in a big
company that they could
go and adapt to a startup now it's
there's always that transition period of
being able to
to scale down and realize you're going
to have fewer people fewer resources you
know i think a lot of the things they
they miss or that they they're surprised
that they lack is the
the financial support the the sales and
marketing support that they had in a big
co
you know they may have they were
probably a specialist in a product
area or technology area but they didn't
realize how much support they were
getting from the big co as they were
developing product in a big co
so as soon as you go to startup you need
to rely upon an ecosystem more
you may not be able to build out in a
startup all the people and all the
resources you need you may not hire a
sales
manager leader first right away out of
the shoot you know that may come later
you may get
cfo help um that's more on loan that's
more part-time
than being able to hire cfo immediately
so you have to do a lot more of
all the different aspects on your own
when you move to a startup
um the only thing i'd say about a big co
is they need help with innovation
in in entrepreneurship you know so you
get this concept of
intrapreneurship and one of the ways i
started working with stanford originally
was was having stanford come to
microsoft and think through
how could we apply internal venture
capital gates to product development
within a big co
because within a big co you start to
lose sort of that um
sometimes that cutting edge
entrepreneurial spirit
in really thinking through you've got to
have the product the financials and the
marketing all together before
even a big co should be funding the
product and so
so you've got that that dynamic going on
internally so so a lot to talk about
you know big ho's acquiring startups
that there's a dynamic there
people leaving a big code to go do a
startup you know you could think about
some that have been successful
um expedia was one from microsoft um
and then also just creating the
entrepreneurial spirit within a big co
you know this intrapreneurism is is a an
opportunity
yeah you know one of the things that i i
think
is most surprising when we're when we're
doing our entrepreneurial education
um programs when we when we meet with
folks who did come
after many years decades in a in a large
organization
is just how scary it is
to start your own company and to do this
you know when
when you're sitting there worried about
making payroll
because that's now your thing when
you're taking money out of your
personal checking account to pay people
because
the pay period is up and people have to
get paid um to realize that
all of those support mechanisms around
compliance
around marketing around financials
around everything
was always sort of in the background you
might you kind of knew it was there but
you didn't realize
how much it was relied upon those are
huge differences
and and look being an entrepreneur being
a founder is one of the greatest
experiences of my life
but it is it's scary
at all it's it's a roller coaster and
and and i think that's one of the things
that i think is is biggest about that
about that culture difference
all right we're gonna we're gonna go um
through a few more questions that have
come in
and some that i that i know that you
have some experience with there's a
question about um
you know precautions about establishing
an entrepreneurial venture and
you know developing countries like nepal
uh i know you've done some work on uh
on entrepreneurship and startup with the
u.n and afghanistan can you talk a
little bit about that
yeah you know um well first of all
startups in a developing country are a
way to really stabilize an economy and
to create jobs and so i think it should
be
a huge focus and priority for
governments in developing post-conflict
countries
it is in some it's not as much in others
i think it should be
now once you do a startup there you know
the
there may not be the infrastructure or
the ecosystem that could support
startups and so
um you know we see that that the
startups are a little bit
hanging on their own you know they don't
have a silicon valley set of
you know part-time cfos you can bring in
or sales and marketing people or even
just
just peers colleagues that where you can
talk about startups
whether it's in your space or your
product space or not
it's it's who do you talk to about this
stuff and so
you know we've we've looked at engineers
and particularly
women female engineers and and started
teaching them things like artificial
intelligence
and then had some coaches some
professors particularly out of japan
and be able to coach them on artificial
intelligence and have them think about
how ai
could be translated into products and
services in afghanistan
and and it's just you know it's just
like blazing a new trail
um to try to get this to happen but the
the the women engineers are so excited
to even
be thinking about this and being able to
see how to make this happen
that they are really ambitious and
passionate um and to stanford's credit
to give kudos to stanford stanford
allowed
modules on innovation and
entrepreneurship to be used for free
for for people um going through these un
programs and so
you know there's some really great
entrepreneurial work going on
in other parts of the world as well
outside of afghanistan iraq
parts of africa um so you know kudos to
the u.n for driving this
not just for women but especially for
women um for for
all all entrepreneurs that are out there
on their own in developing countries and
um and in post-conflict countries i
would say they need to think globally
for partnersh
partnerships and for mentoring and
coaching um so they need to think out of
their region to get help
if they're going to be successful at
least regionally if not globally to
bring in
really great experts to help coach them
on being successful
sure yeah um all right back to one of
one of your uh uh one of your favorite
topics
how do you choose an effective
leadership or executive team for your
startup
yeah well you know again it starts with
the leader
you know it's i you know you've got to
think about this leader as being someone
who
knows the technology enough to work with
the product folks so they may have a
technical background a lot of me and and
yet they're bold and brash enough to be
able to go stand in front of venture
capitalists and sell their idea and get
money
if that's the way they want to do it or
angel investors or or
be smart enough to try to figure out how
to bootstrap it with you know friends
and family
um and then they have to translate into
execution mode of being able to scale
and those
most people don't have all three of
those parts you know are all those
elements
and and so is it a combination i mean
even big companies
they're more successful with a one-two
punch like um
i grew up in intel intel corporation was
great it had andy grove
a visionary technologist great with
business and craig barrett who was an
operations guy who could execute like
crazy you think of apple they had it had
jobs steve jobs
and and um tim cook and you know now
you know jobs jobs is gone um and and
cook is there and so
you know even microsoft when it was bill
gates and steve ballmer there was this
kind of one-two punch and so it may not
just be one person who can do it all
you got to build a team that complements
each other
starting with the leaders but then
really thinking through the team itself
you know who's going to be the best
chief technology officer who's going to
eventually move into sales and marketing
and finances and and is the chemistry
right what criteria do you want from
each of these leaders and then what's
the culture and value set that you're
all going to agree to
you know at least some team charter if
nothing else
let alone identifying the values and
observable cultural behaviors you want
out of the team
and the organization as it starts to
grow that proactive piece will be
really important in serving the startup
well doing it up front
sooner than later than than trying to
you know retrofit it afterwards
but the way i like to think about
startup people is um
the the term and i don't know if i
created it or borrowed it so i'm sorry i
don't really know this
i don't remember the source of it but
the term envisioner
you can envision it you can you can sell
it you can also
engineer it and and execute with
excellent
excellence on it to productize it and
scale it not easy
for one person or even a an effective
set of of team uh members to be able to
go do that
yeah yeah totally totally all right um
so uh somewhat connected to this um
and and and i'll give my viewpoint on
this first and and we'll hear what you
think you know how can someone from a
non-tech background start a company any
suggestions on where and how to start
and i think you know we had talked
before about the importance of
understanding customers
and very often folks that are non-tech
are really great at understanding
customers are
really great at knowing what that market
need is and so therefore
i i would say a non-tech person starts
with really leveraging your skills
around knowing customers and what
customer pain points really
are and how to potentially solve that
burning need that hair on fire need
that a customer has and then you
surround yourself with
the necessary technical folks to deliver
on that need totally agree i think it
starts with customer and going after
these things that maybe the
you know the more serious technical
people don't feel as comfortable doing
um you know it is the customer need it
is the connection
of talking customers creating personas
thinking through the competition the
landscape
you know those all those pieces that are
so needed up front that then complement
what the technical people can go do
i do think a non-technical person can be
very successful but they need to have
credibility with the technical people
or it may not work so they've got to
know enough about the technology be able
to speak to it
and then also in the financials of
course be able to look at the financial
numbers and
and make those decisions those
assumptions that go into the financials
that are both business related and
technical related so they're almost a
bridge between
non-technical and technical and bringing
it all together and they're they're
they're joiners they're connectors
um and it happens at big coast too
that's what a product manager does they
may not be fully technical
but they are the bridge between the the
vision and strategy and all these
pieces that need to happen around go to
market and financials and the technology
people who are building the product
yeah i know like managing that prd right
uh that product requirements document
totally yep um i guess
somewhat connected to this as well uh
how does all this change
if you're offering a service rather than
a product
and does it change i think it does
because
there's a different service mentality
that's needed um you know it's not so
much about product design and
development it's more about
ongoing service and consumption of
services and so
the business model's different the which
means the financials are different the
go to market is different
and so it's just it's just a different
vein that needs to be there's a little
bit of a switch a context switch that
needs to happen
um and we see this at boeing i mean
boeing has a services organization where
you know it looks like there's a 50
billion dollar revenue market there for
services you know maintenance
upgrades of planes training pilots all
this stuff going hasn't really been
involved in in the past
but you know as we work with the the bgs
group the boeing
global services group it's a different
mentality and one thing they always keep
saying to us is
hey we've gotta we've gotta inculcate a
service mindset
it's different we're not like boeing
commercial or boeing defense in space
who are designing and developing
commercial aircraft you know jet
fighters and space
um vehicles it is it is all about a
service
mentality of upgrades and maintenance
and services that we can provide to
customers in an ongoing way
so it's it is a it is a little bit of a
context switch and everything has to
flow with that mentality
yeah right on um
how do you validate a good idea
oh yeah i think people have a good idea
they've gotten some kudos for a good
idea and they call it good
you know and then and then they keep
boldly going with it and
and sort of testing but but even not
listening to people who might question
it over time because they're pretty
convinced it's good
and you kind of need that to be
successful in a startup you need someone
who's pretty bold and brash and going to
you know carry forward because there's
so many factors that can go against you
at the same time you know i'll take a
page from andy grove our ceo from intel
was
you know he wrote a book on this only
the paranoid survive so
how do you be paranoid and go test your
idea how do you go
with many customers in different
segments that you plan to go into
how do you create personas how do you
look at scenarios
where you really think the product is
going to play out and you can validate
this idea
um you go talk to experts go look at the
landscape go
go go to even people outside of the
industry and see if they think it's a
good idea
it's amazing how much people will share
in the entrepreneurial world
i mean everyone's worried oh no i
shouldn't share my ideas someone's going
to steal it
it's actually that the more people you
talk to and get feedback to validate
your idea
and you share that you find new partners
and you find you get great advice
and and they're they're probably not
going to steal your idea you can you can
create an mba if you're really worried
but if your idea is stealable
just by sharing it then you probably
don't have enough intellectual property
protection you probably don't have
enough
you know trade secret protection or
anything it will be stolen by someone
else
eventually yeah or if if you're that
scared about it you know what one of the
other things is i actually think the
question
is almost somewhat misphrased in that
you don't validate a good idea
others validate your idea
yeah and it's true i think you know if
you have a good idea
you have some what we like to refer to
as secret sauce right there's some
secret sauce you have
you're probably not going to give away
all the details of it but you're sharing
the overall idea
and if someone can replicate your secret
sauce well probably not
um and just to what you're saying i
think mike is is you
you don't validate everyone else does
and you've got to go do the due
diligence so you've got to have
you do or someone on your team's got to
go do that and
and this is where again someone who's
maybe non-technical can go do this or
someone who's technical and maybe
um is golden because maybe they've
gotten a technical mba or
they have some of that business acumen
and business savvy can go out and do
this as well
so two last quick questions um how does
an individual introduce and encourage
intrapreneurship in a company and i know
you spent
decades doing this exact thing yeah
well you know i had a um well i kind of
had a poster child at microsoft that i
used to love
um we spent microsoft a lot of money
tens of millions on development of a
product which was the original surface
if you remember the original surface
wasn't a laptop it was a
coffee table and and it could do a few
things it could absorb your photos off
your phone
and you know it could do certain things
but um
you know it was it was technology
because it was proving out some new
technology
and and so the poster child was that you
know should we spend tens of millions to
do r d
on something like that when there really
wasn't a market for it
you know it wasn't it could be
productized but there was no scale
no one no one's buying it it ended up
being in lobbies of
um cell phone stores and you know where
people had to wait
or doctor's offices you know i don't
know if any of you on the line have an
original surface the coffee table
it's pr probably not it's in a museum so
so in my mind it
it it's it's got to be you know
something where
it can scale and you can introduce ideas
uh within a company to say look we we've
got to be careful with shareholder money
we shouldn't do r d just for r d sake
let's really be smart about bringing
together the product idea the marketing
the finances
and so that's what we did is bring
together a team up front of financial
people
go to market people and product people
and said let's get smarter up front
about the product idea
get that signed off in a series of gates
um within a company like microsoft
and and then we know that we're we're
better um with a viable product for the
market than
if we just you know spend money on
creating technology for technology's
sake now
all that technology that was created was
used and carried forward and the name
surface that was trademarked is
well you know it's used in a big way so
it wasn't all lost it was just that we
felt we could do it better
than the way we were doing it and so i
think you know being able to explain
that story and get people bought into
that concept for entrepreneurism is
is really vital if you're doing this in
a big company
totally um so last question quick answer
i have
my thoughts as well when's it time to
walk away
from a startup versus pivoting oh
wow you know i've seen startups pivot a
lot
and you know i think when you see that
the financials don't work and the
product's not working or there's someone
else in the market
who's taken over in um and you just you
know you kind of run up against the wall
and
you're not you're not seeing customers
gravitate towards you or
it's it's impossible to acquire them
anymore you're starting to see it slow
down and
no matter what you try it's not working
um i think people should
should not be afraid of failure you know
first of all
you should iterate rapid prototype when
you're in a startup so you learn from
failure fast and pivot
you know as you need to not so fast
you're whiplashing your entire team
but pivot as you need to and do
everything you can to be successful
but then you know also not be afraid to
walk away if you have to
the most successful entrepreneurs have
failed multiple times
and so i think we as humans have this
fear of failure and and
we you know it's just learning it's all
just learning
bill gates always said the best learning
is when we fail it's not when we're
successful we don't learn enough
it's it's when you fail for sure you
know i i guess i would say you can pivot
forever you can bootstrap forever
when the passion's gone that's when you
have to wrap it up
so um in that line i want to thank
dr michael force from boeing for joining
us today
for those that are out there if you're
looking for more help in launching your
startup
check out our idea to market online
course which is linked
in your webinar console and once again
thanks michael for joining us today it's
really been a pleasure thank you mike
for having me
thanks for inviting me great to be here
i'm just unplugged as a resource here
for anyone who needs help so um glad
glad to be with you all
awesome hannah thank you all for joining
us today
i think this was absolutely fabulous
we've heard from some of our viewers
that you are
both extremely quotable so
just fyi again thank you all for joining
us
um thank you fors and lepik this was
really awesome
and we look forward to
talking to you all again thank you all
again so much
and have a great day